let's get a question right here that
came in for you guys and uh
oh that's anthony you know him yeah
hey how's it going my name is anthony
out of san antonio and
the question for the auctioneers i had
was what's the craziest thing
that y'all auctioned off and how much
was it
gang gang gang anthony thank you bro for
the question man
now that's a good that that's a good one
yeah where does that land
vasectomy really yeah that clip huh yeah
and how did somebody have a free when
they had a yeah so it was at a uh
a gala event oh yeah and uh yeah it was
just
one of those items that they put up
there i don't remember what it sold for
i'm sure it was like 10 000 bucks or so
but that was that was the craziest thing
for sure just the back story of some
wife and husband sitting there bidding
on a damn yeah i don't want anymore
she's raising the bed yeah
you know and he's wondering what the
hell is going on she knows she's
planning on maybe divorcing down the
line so she's trying to uh
you know uh limit the inheritance down
yeah
crazy cars too but yeah vasectomy was
definitely the uh
for me i think the uh one time i think
me and him were working together and i
think we sold
a yellow lab puppy for like 60 thousand
oh yeah absolutely no way
was that seabiscuit or whatever damn it
was it was an event it was a it was a
fundraiser for a medical uh group and
i mean it was yeah it was in sellers
dogs dogs go crazy at those events it
was a puppy
i bet that mostly labs maybe it was like
a sound or
part of it you know what i'm saying that
famous dog that died in that movie
sounder
but damn sixty thousand i think the
highest priced car i've ever sold was i
wasn't
actually auctioneer and i was working
the ring uh in houston texas
and it was a bentley for 330 000.
there was a i worked in auction in
amelia island florida classic car sale
and it was a car that i think porsche
and ferrari one of those types of cars
they built like two of these cars
together this was one it was literally a
rust bucket
9500 dollars is what it sold for
and i was working the floor the ring
like he was and why why why i think it's
just collector it was a collector i mean
they're
so rare there's only a couple of them i
don't know whatever
i guess i don't know i have no idea well
in my situation
330 000 bentley was in my mind
at dealer cost and they were going to go
sell it for 550 retail wow
yeah man and we're talking about
this happening somebody spending 330 000
in a matter a matter of 25 to 45 seconds
and so if that bid and starts out at 10
000 or something like
how quick like how do you know when to
differentiate between a bid you're
seeing on the floor and a bid that's
that you are getting sent up to you from
the ring
it i mean you're you're both seeing the
same thing
so you're both on the same wavelength
and if the bit let's say the bid starts
at 10 grand and there's eight people
down there just
just bid and bid and bidding you'll go
from ten one two two and a half five
you'll jump it up to two and a half five
seven and a half eleven eleven two and a
half five seven half twelve
i mean it you know you you you read you
read the crowd like that just like
just like you do it gets exciting huh
it's very exciting
fast space too i think people like just
hearing people count remember they had
that um
you know especially where i'm from dude
if somebody could count how you thought
they were doing damn magic you know
uh i mean half my neighborhood couldn't
count yeah you know what i'm saying we
have people you told them about 11 they
[ __ ]
know what you're talking about you know
what i'm saying yeah like after 10 they
thought it had something to do with
satan you know it was real
just kind of novice numerical types you
know oh yeah um
what is uh take me through some of that
bidding like give me
show me a little bit of that magic you
know you want some magic yeah like if
we're bidding on something you know
um how do you know like what what are
some bids people do do people still do
the thing
like they touch their face and then like
some people will turn away from you and
like
tap their leg or tap their head no and
then wink at you yeah shake their head
no winky to you
and they hide from each other yeah play
games with each other oh yeah really
oh yeah yeah it's fun and you you and
you're sitting up here
yeah so you see all the games
they mess with each other yeah but you
get involved with the games with them
totally they're yeah they're there's
some rivalries out there you know
you know there'll be people where's the
money where's the money and you're like
i'm fixing to show you i got it so
you'll know you'll know and sometimes
the audience won't know that like who's
doing it
yeah and guys over there in the corner
just oh they they play with each other
so much
and it's more so the the the experienced
and the skilled
dealers versus the younger newcomers
oh yeah that that that don't know
because there's there's there's always a
new dealer that comes into the auction
and doesn't have a clue as to what's
going on wow he's just standing out
front like this
yeah and you know the first two or three
months or an education
or an exit yeah because he's he could be
spending too much oh yeah
yeah i mean he can't get him sold if if
he doesn't get it figured out i mean
he's going to exit the business because
he owes a bunch of money
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one